why do you think that is that they call
you there's really it's occupation they
don't want both units exist that's
simple to me you know I can I understand
that but that not doesn't make it right
this is a Palestinian Bedouin village
that's been here since before Israel was
created but the state considers this
village illegal and has tried to
forcibly remove its residents multiple
times but they've resisted and that's
meant living cut off from basic services
you guys aren't even on the map of
Israel no or not but you're Israeli
citizens yes we kind of are kind of kind
of because officially we are but that
that's not how do you that do I feel I
feel so what do you what do you feel
like you are I first of all I'm
balancing and I'm definitely a
Palestinian and if I was in Israeli
citizen then I am a second class or
maybe third one not because the country
doesn't treat me as other citizens ours
for example Jews also noog is one of 35
unrecognized Palestinian Bedouin
villages home to around 70,000 people
they've been under constant threat of
displacement since Israel's founding in
1948 in 2013 a bill was proposed to
evict most of the villagers and force
them into government built on ships in
some cases Jewish communities would
replace them after widespread protests
Israeli officials said they would shelve
the plan but home demolitions have
continued including investments what is
this structure right here well this is
to hide the fact that they're building
inside it you know because it's illegal
to build any any building any any it
small even small room so if if they see
it they'll put it down so you hide the
fact that you're building
huelga who will put it down estate in
fact just weeks before our visit Israel
demolished homes in the nearby village
of a lot of key for the 90th time so
what does it mean to be unrecognized and
not be on the map it's not to have
electricity the way it's supposed to be
done it's not to have infrastructures
it's not to have streets the way it's
supposed to be it's not to have sewer
systems it's not to have play yards and
all of the children right now they just
play in a while then that's
not good that's dangerous what are the
people the residents of the village
wanted to build a playground for the
kids that allowed putting two stones
together is considered illegal yeah
building anything is considered illegal
what is this this is its own banner so
you're showing us how the solar panel
you can move it no way yeah so depending
on where the Sun is you get electricity
for the house so these are these are the
batteries that are charging so like on a
rainy day or in the winter you have to
rely on this yes and sometimes you know
it's it's out mm-hmm it turns out so you
don't have electricity then yeah you're
just engage in a very illegal activity
right now what is it building a house
there are tens of thousands of people
who live exactly like us and they also
have to go take this risk
yeah this would I have any other
alternative I mean I can't issue I can't
go to the Italian Ministry and the issue
like building permit because this place
doesn't exist for them Israel says
developing the Negev desert is one of
its most important missions its Ministry
of Foreign Affairs said in a statement
that Israel seeks to integrate villagers
into its development plans but residents
like Bessemer read between the lines
what does Israel want with this land
basically well to the Jews on it will
simply not not Arabs not Palestinians
because you know we're not really
welcome here because it's new this is a
new house yeah you're saying the roofs
they really are made yeah there but you
know they they make another construction
to cover that they didn't do it yet
because it's a bit expensive
you guys are like constant like handy
men yeah constant repairs huh you must
you know that's how you look
what does it feel like to constantly
have to battle this state just to remain
in your home and in your village that's
life and you just called it resistance
oh yeah my life is true you know I
resist to live that's that's I think
that that's a basic thing every human
being do but simply you know we do a
different light sometimes it's against
the wind sometimes it's against the
state